what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with invincible yes we are now
in the last video that we did uh we
basically picked up with the idea that
mark had essentially been gone for like
five years right he had just literally
been yanked away and he was kind of
going back and reliving his life and
making different decisions and so on but
when the time came for him to decide
whether or not this new life was the
life he wanted or to simply go back to
his old life mark chose to go back to
his old life and in a lot of ways eve
and his daughter were basically the
anchor right they were the thing that he
had that he knew he had that he just
simply didn't have in this alternate
life and so the result was that once he
returned five years had passed and so
the result of this is that as he shows
up here of course seeing his daughter
for the first time and then realizing
she's aged up five years what's really
hard hitting here is the fact that he
missed so much time and he doesn't have
the ability to time travel right it's
one of the big things that makes
invincible so different to other comic
book stories he can't go back into the
past so those five years are gone and
those are five years that he'll simply
never be able to get back now of course
eve is also exceedingly excited to see
him as well of course heartbroken by
everything but one of the things that
goes on here is mark kind of tells her
everything that was happening with
regards to the the whole experience he
went through the the idea he was given a
separate choice and so on and so forth
but in the end what also really hits him
is the fact that he's just missed so
much right he's just missed so much of
his daughter's life the first time she
walked the first time she talked all
that stuff those are things that were
basically gone and while i am not a
parent myself i also have to believe
that's a hugely traumatic experience for
a parent right whether it's because
they're locked up in jail or because
some circumstance took them away from
their child right military life or
something along those lines coming back
and then the the reality of the
situation hitting you that you've just
missed all that all that time and those
are moments that you can never get back
it's got to be hard but it's got to be a
very very difficult thing now the other
part about this is that again this is
everybody right everybody's aged up five
years so when mark meets oliver i mean
one oliver looks pretty damn dapper not
even gonna lie
[Laughter]
oliver looks pretty good right he kind
of reminds me of like howard stark right
from from the the iron man comics but
he's aged up five years as well his life
is aged up five years like a lot has
happened and one of the things we're
gonna see here is that all this stuff
that's gone on that a lot of things have
changed and not everything has changed
for the good now the other part of this
is that with mark and eve basically
spending time together one of the things
that she reveals is that while she had
been built a kind of house you know for
herself and so on you know for her and
uh and tara that at the same time there
was also somebody else during this time
period right there was somebody else
during this five year period now the
important thing to understand here is
the reason for that is because as far as
eve was concerned mark was dead remember
up until that point when mark was gone
he was only gone for a few months right
three months six months maybe a year so
but he was never really gone for like a
five year period the fact that nobody
had any news about him the fact that
nobody had heard anything it would make
good sense that she would just move on i
mean the alternative is for her to just
spend the rest of her life waiting on
him to come back which may never happen
you know i mean in truth the guy did but
ultimately she didn't know that the
other part of this is that when i say
not everything that changed is good that
you actually pick up with oliver and of
course his wife is tending to their
children and so on he basically goes
into the office to have a video call and
the questions asked are there any
updates on your brother only for us to
find out he's talking to general thrack
that what's happening here is that
somewhere along the line oliver sided
with threat somewhere during this
five-year window he ended up becoming
what is in effect a spy for the
viltromide empire or at least for for
thrag himself within the coalition of
worlds and so the thing about this and
what's what's really kind of crazy here
is that ultimately you end up basically
having this scenario where um where
where allen the alien is essentially
kind of called to the the the systems
right called to the the meeting place of
the coalition of planets only to find
out that there's essentially a kind of
coup d'etat that's in the process of
happening that if you guys recall in the
last video that we did that it was
basically revealed to alan the alien
that not everybody who was in the
coalition of worlds was friendly not all
of them thought that he was an effective
leader and it was one of those things
where kirkland was kind of telling us
it's only going to be a matter of time
before somebody makes the move to take
him out and that's exactly what's
happening that people see him as what is
in effect an ineffective leader and so
in an effort to take him out and replace
him with somebody else because he's the
one that basically runs everything going
on in relation to the military and all
that kind of stuff it's not as though
you can just just kill him off by
ordering the military to do it you can't
really have like a vote of no confidence
or anything like that ultimately they
just gotta destroy him which of course
doesn't work
it doesn't really happen at all and in
fact this guy who's basically leading
the coup this member of the of the
coalition actually has a detonator in
his hand and when he sets it off of
course it'll take him out which doesn't
really matter to him because the
ultimate goal is to kill alan the alien
but of course allen ends up surviving
albeit in small little pieces
small little tidbits right he barely
makes it and so at this point we switch
back over to earth and we actually end
up joining up with rex now we don't know
exactly who it is he's talking to but
he's addressing someone and simply
saying i know how you feel and i respect
it you see what they've done how they've
set back what we've been trying to
accomplish by years world peace will be
a generation before the people of this
planet can believe it's real this was a
war unlike anything we've ever seen do
what you know has to be done he says
this wouldn't be you slipping back to
the old ways of your people look at that
monster look at what he's done he has
poisoned himself and drained countless
worlds to stay alive he'll never stop
he'll do this again if not to us some
other innocent world and that's we
basically end up finding out he's
talking to nolan that seemingly nolan
has joined the forces of rex right he's
joined the forces of robot and now he's
fighting on his side and it just makes
good sense but we'll actually get the
perspective of nolan here in a little
while of course at that point you
basically have the moment where mark
ends up meeting the boyfriend or at
least the former boyfriend of adam eve
uh while mark was gone now here's an
important thing to understand how it is
that people deal with the perceived
breakups or the deaths of a loved one in
terms of like a partner or something
like that those are wide and varying
some people don't recuperate for months
some people don't recuperate for years
or i guess recover is the way to phrase
that for some people it takes months or
years or what have you others are right
back in there again for the ones who are
right back in there as i understand it
from the different books that i've read
it's usually filling a hole right you
can't really build an actual
relationship based off of that uh but
the reality is that for this particular
guy here on the surface he just i mean
he's kind of like this muscular guy
right he's really well built the reality
is the person he is on the inside and
what you'll actually find out is the
guy's a prick right so one of the things
that happens is that in basically with
alan being injured this guy along with
his sister just kind of showed up here
now the the story given here is well you
know we heard we heard that that allen
was injured you know he wanted to stop
by but the reality is he wanted to talk
to eve and that while mark is there you
know he says like can we talk alone and
she says no anything that you can say to
me you can say in front of mark and he's
like i mean if you really want me to but
he's like okay like you are a vibrant
energetic creature and you deserve to be
happy it makes me ill to know that you
let archaic familial obligation weigh
you down you should live for you he says
and i know he can never make you feel
the way that i made you feel and of
course she freaks out and immediately
attacks him now one of the things to
know and it's i've heard of people doing
this that's a way that you kind of
weasel in to like a grieving person man
or woman women do it to men men do it to
women but it's like look you know i get
that you're struggling let me be your
shoulder to cry on while you're going
through these tough times you know and
then ultimately if they're really just
kind of a sleazy person they'll use that
to worm their way in right it's a it's a
pretty shady thing to do the thing about
this is that once you basically have a
sister that kind of pokes her head out
she basically says like eve absolutely
loved my brother they were good together
uh he made her happy the problem was eve
was too attached to that little child
that you guys have and when he asked her
to choose between her that little girl
and him she chose a little girl now let
me tell you guys something that's how i
know that guy is a dick any man that
would run up on a single mom and say you
need to choose between your child or me
that guy is an idiot because i can't
really think of very many single moms
[Laughter]
that would put their love interest above
their child but any reasonable human
being would not right no real reasonable
human being would do that and so again
that's one of those things where it's
just kind of like no like this is never
gonna happen like that's just never ever
ever going to happen
so it makes sense the two of them ended
up going their own separate ways but at
that point we switch over to thrag
himself and the crazy thing about this
is that if you guys recall the previous
videos we've done one of the things that
i guess freddie mercury i keep
forgetting to call him freddie mercury
one of the things that freddie mercury
had done is he had actually traveled to
other worlds and basically started
seeding offspring on those other worlds
the goal of course to build up what he
could consider to be something as close
to the vulture might empire as he could
get with no more pure-blooded vulture
mites that were on his side remember
like they all basically turned against
him and sided with nolan he couldn't
really bring the vulture might race back
to its proper place uh because there
were no more pure blood velcro mites
left there so the next best thing is to
basically make what are in effect more
olivers right that's the race that he's
procreating with but with his children
at least these two individual children
he's essentially grooming them that that
he basically teaches them how to engage
in conflict he teaches them the nature
of the viltrumite race to engage in
warfare to fight to basically look at
all of the other races across the the
galaxy in the universe as basically
being uh being lesser than right
basically saying like our job is to rule
them right that's what we do so teaching
them to be ruthless teaching them to be
cold and calculating that's all really
what goes into this now one of the other
things that goes on is if you guys
recall anisia she was the one who
sexually assaulted mark and for a long
time mark kept it to himself but
ultimately he ended up revealing it to
uh to adam eve and when that happened
when he basically dumped that
information on adam eve her immediate
response is we need to do something but
mark didn't want to now one part of that
was kind of the victim's mentality which
is you know
it was probably something that i did or
something along those lines basically
blaming themselves but the other part
was there was just too much at stake
right if he went to his father if he
went to nolan and said like hey i know
you're the leader of the vulture might
race uh anesia had basically sexually
assaulted me one it would be openly
admitting it which which would basically
crush any self-esteem he had which kind
of goes into the victim mentality but
two it could potentially fracture the
vulture might race now of course
maintaining his own mental health is way
more important than the success of the
filter might race but the point that i'm
making here is that when people go
through those exceedingly hard
experiences they don't always make the
most logical decisions that emotion
largely ends up taking over and so as a
result of that we actually end up
finding out that what appears to have
been the case is that anisia had
basically gotten pregnant and that in
doing so she ended up giving birth to a
child that she named markley now the
reason why i say this is basically the
child of mark is because this kid looks
like they're about five years old right
it looks like that's the case the
timeline fits perfectly so when she had
initially assaulted mark she ended up
becoming pregnant and then of course
gave birth to his child but following
this you basically switch over to mark
and nolan meeting up with uh with robot
right meeting up with rex and this again
is where things get really really
interesting here right in the statement
that he makes to them he says like do
you know how many people died in this
invasion attempt right obviously some
other dimensional alien race tried to
invade or successfully invaded but was
ultimately repelled and he says
1513. he says i don't mean to be proud
of the deaths of so many people but that
was an achievement that should be
recognized we're only a week and a
cleanup and already the building process
is well underway he says people are
scared but they're safe and they are fed
steps are already being taken to prevent
these kinds of things from happening in
the future and he says it's not just the
ones you knew as heroes who are helping
in the efforts even the villains have
united under my leadership for the good
of all and he says a place for
everything and everything in its place
he says i've learned if you find out
what a villain wants and you give it to
them well then you have an ally power
respect money help them meet their goal
on your terms then the other people the
bad stuff becomes less important and
they become productive members of
society and he says i'm glad to say as
time goes on more and more of our
friends are starting to see things my
way after all you can't argue with
results there are still a few holdouts
but they don't interfere they keep their
distance and in the case of monster girl
and monarchs they even pitch in when
help is needed don't let the current
state of people fool you people are
happy and life is good and this is a
statement that he's making to mark and
to nolan it's really more to mark than
anything else because nolan is already
on the side of robot it's really more to
mark than it is nolan because nolan's
already on the side of robot right it's
basically trying to convince mark and
that's when the two of them basically
take off into space and they have this
discussion and nolan makes this case
where the two of them are talking and
he's like look it was understandable
when this all first started that you
would be avidly against it because there
were no results there was no evidence to
indicate that he was actually doing a
good thing you simply had to take him at
his word and all he had shown you up to
that point was that he had launched a
massive campaign against all those
superheroes that he knew right off the
bat would turn against him and then left
those that he was unsure about to make
their own choices but he had by your
measurement turned against the superhero
community but now we're five years in we
have results the reality here mark
whether you agree with it or not is the
world is a better place crime is at an
all-time low people are not starving
there is no more economic or social
inequality in the world the world is
better than it's ever been he's like
initially rex didn't really have a face
a face to this stuff he just kind of
operated in secret operated in the
shadows but ultimately he made himself
public and that when the time came when
a new president was elected he never ran
instead people wrote him in people loved
him so much that they actually added him
to the ballot and then voted for him
that way but when it was revealed that
he had basically won the office of the
presidency he turned it down he's not
looking for absolute power mark he's not
looking to be king he's not looking to
to run the country or the world or
anything like that you know and that's
where mark really in a lot of ways kind
of starts grasping at straws and it's
like well i mean what makes you think
that this alien invasion wasn't
something he orchestrated right in order
to make himself look good to everybody
right to stay in everybody's good graces
in reality what mark is doing is looking
for reasons to maintain his possession
all the evidence contradicts everything
that mark is saying there's nothing here
to indicate that people don't have
freedoms there's nothing here to
indicate that they can't speak ill
against uh against rex or anything like
that if anything they have no reason to
they absolutely love him and that's kind
of the interesting thing is it's
basically mark just grasping at straws
well no there's got to be some kind of a
problem here there's got to be something
wrong with what's going on here and i
will discover it there's got to be
something there's no way that we can
have some situation where a person of
their own volition and from a place of
being altruistic basically seizes power
and then makes the world better the
reality here is that's entirely the case
that the whole of human history kind of
reflects the fact that if people wanted
things to be better they would be better
but people are slow to change and
oftentimes people will fight against
change and the reality as far as rex
realized it was if people will not
change of their own accord and if people
will not make the world better then i
will make them and ultimately people
sided with that right they respected a
good leader that drugged them into the
future even if it had to be done kicking
and screaming and so that's the crazy
thing about that right that's the crazy
thing is that it really seems to to
point to this idea that at the end of
the day superheroes basically exist for
the purpose of maintaining the status
quo that's all they really seem to exist
to do but when you have somebody who
comes along and and flies in the face of
that and says no no no we as superheroes
should not be maintaining the status quo
we should be making people better
whether they want to be or not suddenly
it doesn't seem to happen as bad as it
may have been before now again there is
a lot more going on here than we're
initially led to believe but it
basically looks like rex is the good guy
here right and mark is the bad guy
trying to find a problem with a great
situation and so the results of this is
that you basically end up picking up
with general thrag of course uh who
essentially tells the two of his
children like i have trained you i've
taught you everything you need to know
to become highly formidable assets i
have a final mission for you and he says
your mission is to kill mark right your
mission is to go back and to kill
invincible word has reached my ears that
he has returned we will destroy him
because of his actions in destroying uh
at least being a part of the destruction
of the vulture might race he can't
readily launch an attack on nolan
because the v what's left of the
villager might race sees nolan as their
leader if if freddie mercury were to
show up here and attack nolan on earth
the villager mites would kill him right
they would ultimately end up destroying
him right that was the promise that was
made if you come back here we will kill
you so you stay away we stay away and
that'll basically be it now of course he
also contacts oliver to let him know
what's going on and all oliver begs
right begs and please please do not kill
my brother right do not kill mark but
the response of freddie mercury is it's
already set in motion right this is your
test this is a test of your loyalty if
you are truly on my side you will let
this happen you will let your brother
die but if you turn against me if you
try to save the life of your brother
then i will know what side you're truly
on right i will know where your
loyalties truly lie and so while you
have mark and you've got tara and you've
got adam eve who are just enjoying a
beautiful day you know at home where you
were terrorists playing outside suddenly
they're met by the children of freddie
mercury right who immediately attacked
them right who immediately just started
going off and attacking all of them now
one of the big things to know about tara
is despite the fact that she has
seemingly inherited the powers of mark
she's never really used them before and
so the results of this is that she
doesn't know how to fly or anything like
that and that while she is essentially
taken by mark and he flies as fast as as
he can she hasn't learned how to breathe
while flying and so for her it's like
suffocating you know and that's why he
tells her you need to take a deep breath
right take as deep of a breath as you
possibly can and then we'll like and
then we got to take off again right like
we need to get you someplace safe and
then i will come back and i will deal
with this fight myself and so ultimately
the sun catches up to mark while the
daughter is battling eve and in a lot of
ways the fights seem pretty even now one
of the things here when it comes to eve
is is she probably the most powerful
person that exists in the universe just
in terms of raw power yes but how she
uses her power has largely been pretty
small right she used it when she was
doing things like fixing the environment
and all that kind of stuff right
altering the the biological structure
and the biosphere of the earth in just
huge ways but when she engages in a
conflict here she uses them pretty small
time right i mean i guess she could just
simply phase this girl out of existence
or turn her into something else so
whatever the case happens to be but in
the end she uses her powers in a pretty
basic way and a lot of that is because
adam eve doesn't want to kill this girl
remember adam even mark don't readily
kill people unless they absolutely have
to it's more about defeating her right
basically capturing her you know
essentially getting her to stop right
that's really all it is but the fight's
pretty drawn out now of course once the
sun catches up to mark and the two of
them start fighting then mark
immediately starts pummeling this kit
the ultimate thing here though is that
the sun basically grabs terra and then
drops her from this enormous height
because he knows tara doesn't seem to
have any powers or at least doesn't seem
to know how to use her powers if she
does have them and so where the
expectation is she'll just crash into
the ground and just hit as hard as
possible she ultimately ends up flying
right now it's really more floating than
anything else but of course she doesn't
hit she has no idea how to use her
powers she has no idea what to do but
it's one of those things where it's like
okay cool she's safe until freddie
mercury arrives on the scene and then
grabs her and of course we know that she
would stand no chance against freddie
mercury right freddie murphy would
absolutely crush this girl and in fact
where he goes to kill her right where he
goes to take her out oliver shows up and
oliver basically ends up fighting off
against freddie mercury and essentially
siding with mark now it's a very sad
turn of events here because ultimately
oliver tells tara go and go and find
your father right oliver knows his state
is his fate is sealed he knows that
going against freddie mercury like this
he can't go toe-to-toe with this guy he
cannot stand against freddie mercury
remember freddie mercury was orders of
magnitude stronger than oliver was when
they first met and that while oliver has
grown stronger as he's aged so is
freddie mercury and so in effect he'll
just never be as strong as freddie
mercury is right oliver's strength and
capabilities could increase by 50 levels
but by that point by the time he gets to
where general thrag was general thrag
will be 50 levels higher above him right
it is an even distribution it just kind
of continues at the same rate and so
because of this there's no conceivable
way for oliver to survive and so with
that being the case you ultimately have
mark who basically shows up to uh to
adam eve and helps her helps her
basically incapacitate the daughter and
then of course you have this whole fight
going on between oliver and uh and
freddie mercury and ultimately freddie
mercury just like impales oliver right
punches him through the gut and that
essentially kills him and then following
that you end up having mark who shows up
on the scene with the son of freddie
mercury and he says you have something
of mine i have something of yours you
have my daughter i have your son i
suggest that we have an even exchanged
and the response of freddie mercury is
no i know you're not going to kill my
son right you're a hero like you're a
guy who does good things you you you
save the day you don't kill mark do not
do not give me this brave face right do
not give me this face that like you know
you would be willing to destroy my son
if i was willing to destroy your
daughter you've never been that man and
you never will be that man and he's like
i will kill your daughter here and then
i will watch you cry and i will watch
your world fall apart and then once
that's done i will kill you and he's
like once my son is safe then i will
kill you and then i will kill eve and
the ultimate response that mark gives is
being a hero is [ __ ] and he snaps
the head of of of freddie mercury's son
right off his shoulders kills his son on
the spot and then in turn goes directly
after freddie mercury at that point
freddie mercury is incensed right one
because mark has basically defied every
possible line of logic that he ever
could have imagined actually being the
case and the second reason for this is
because mark killed his son and so the
two of these guys are fighting with
absolute anger and hatred not only that
the daughter jumps back onto the scene
again and the daughter completely
enraged at the fact that mark had killed
her brother absolutely pummels adam eve
and then in doing that smashes her mouth
in and then basically kills her when
that happens you end up having a freddie
mercury who rips mark in half and so in
effect both mark and adam eve are
basically killed here right they're
totally destroyed and so the result of
this is that where freddie mercury and
his daughter essentially take off right
they end up leaving and it's just like
we're done here right let this girl
grieve in front of her dead parents let
that experience soak in that what ends
up happening is it turns out adam eve is
not actually dead right she's severely
injured but she's not really dead and
and what i don't necessarily know how i
feel about she ends up activating her
powers she heals herself and mark they
return back to 100 completely and
totally healed even with new outfits and
the response of adam eve is we can't sit
on the sidelines anymore we can't stand
out here and just let freddie mercury
exist out there and do some things that
yes we've been trying to stay off the
radar we've been we've been keeping to
ourselves because we have a daughter but
the reality here is that we're in a war
now and this will be the war to end all
wars when the smoke clears and the dust
settles it'll be us or them who are
basically left alive we have to train
our daughter how to fight and we have to
be willing to fight ourselves with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end we have two videos left
and after that invincible's done right
basically the war to end all wars
technically it's called the end of
everything parts one and two but it's
the war to end all wars and let me tell
you guys it is phenomenal uh we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i'll catch you all later
peace